كما اعلنت باكستان ان رئيس حكومتها انور
الحق كاكار قطع مشاركته في منتدى دافوس
بسويسرا بسبب التوتر المستجد على الحدود
مع ايران وقالت المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه
الباكستانيه ان وزير خارجيه البلاد قطع
للغايه نفسها مشاركته في مؤتمر يعقد في
اوغندا واضافت المتحدثه ان حكومه بلادها
ستستمر في التواصل مع دول الجوار من اجل
محاربه الارهاب مشير الى ان الضربه التي
نفذتها او نفذها الجيش الباكستاني صباح
اليوم في ايران كانت بناء على معلومات
استخباريه معنا من امام مقر وزاره
الخارجيه الباكستانيه في اسلام اباد مدير
مكتب الجزيره عبد الرحمن مطر الرحمن تصريح
المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه هل اشار الى ما
يمكن ان يحدث الان بعد تلك الضربات
يعني الموقف الباكستاني الان بعد تاكيد
اسلاماباد شنها تلك الغاره او تلك الضربات
العسكريه داخل داخل الاراضي الايرانيه
واضح جدا من انه ان باكستان لا تريد تصعيد
الموقف اكثر من ذلك
واستدعاء او يعني قطع رئيس الحكومه زيارته
وايضا وزير الخارجيه زيارته
لافريقيا دليل على ان باكستان حقيقه ربما
تكون قد اتخذت كل الاجراءات السياسيه
الدبلوماسيه وحتى العسكريه الملائمه للوضع
الراهن والذي تسببت به ايران بحسب
المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الباكستانيه عندما
هاجمت فجر يوم امس مواقع داخل الاراضي
الباكستانيه على مقربه من الحدود
الباكستانيه الايرانيه ما دفع باكستان
لسحب سفيرها ومنع السفير الايراني من
العوده ل مقر عمله هنا في اسلام اباد
وايقاف اللقاءات الثنائيه بين البلدين
واليوم هذا الضربه هذه الضربه التي كانت
عباره عن سلسله من الضربات العسكريه لسته
اهداف في ثلاث مواقع تسببت بحسب المصادر
الباكستانيه بسقوط عدد من القتلى وبينهم
عدد من المطلوبين المتهمين بممارسه
الارهاب داخل الاراضي الباكستانيه المصادر
الموثوقه اكدت لنا ان الضربه التي وجهت
اليوم كانت متنوعه بين صواريخ موجهه عاليه
الدقه وطائرات مسيره ايضا استخدمت في
الضربات التي نفذت اليوم من قبل القوات
المسلحه الباكستانيه على المستوى السياسي
وزاره الخارجيه الباكستانيه والمتحدث
باسمها اكدت بان باكستان ليست معنيه
بالتصعيد اكثر من ذلك وانها مستعده للعمل
مع دول الجوار
لمحاوله مكافحه الارهاب او التصدي لما
يسمى بالارهاب في الاقليم لكن باكستان
بالتاكيد موقفها كان واضح على المستوى
السياسي الدبلوماسي وحتى العسكري من
التجاوز والاختراق الكبير غير القانوني
لسيادتها الذي نفذته ايران بدايه فجر يوم
امس